bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 3 décembre
jean castex appelle les français à se
faire vacciner un acte altruiste selon
lui la stratégie de vaccination en
compte le comique a été détaillé tout à
l'heure par le premier ministre
progressive gratuité en trois étapes
la campagne n'est plus qu'une question
de semaines
un million personnes devraient être
vaccinés dès janvier dans les ehpad ce
sera ensuite au tour des personnes
vulnérables puis le grand public à
partir du printemps de nombreuses
réactions après la mort de valéry
giscard d'estaing qui s'était éteint
hier à l'âge de 94 ans des suites du coc
vide ses obsèques ont eu lieu auront
lieu à samedi à hotton dans le loir et
cher chez lui
l'ancien chef de l'état de 1974 à 80 a
consacré une grande partie de sa vie à
l'union européenne est aussi marqué un
grand intérêt pour le continent africain
sont son mandat la france était très
active nous reviendrons notamment sur la
politique giscardienne en afrique
l'otan au premier semestre 2021 pourrait
se tenir un sommet avec la nouvelle
administration byden de quoi redonner du
souffle un bloc
atlantis qui a publié hier un rapport au
temps 2030 selon lequel la chine va
devenir dans la prochaine décennie je
cite le deuxième pire ennemi de
l'alliance après la russie à pékin vait
fait savoir qu'elles étaient prêtes à
engager un dialogue avec l'alliance
[Musique]
jean castex a donc tenu une conférence
de presse tout à l'heure sur la
stratégie vaccinale et la lutte contre
le coc vide
pour plus de précisions nous retrouvons
tout de suite notre reporter qui a suivi
cette allocution pour nous katia
technique avenue de ségur boussouar
katia alors que doit-on retenir de cette
nouvelle prise de parole du premier
ministre oui alors jean castex a donc
détaillé les conditions et date de cette
campagne vaccinale alors il a tout
d'abord détaillé le fait que le
confinement tel qu'il est actuellement
allait encore durer deux semaines mais
des restrictions vont se poursuivre
comme par exemple un petit conseil ne
mettre que six personnes durant les
fêtes
sans compter les enfants mais revenons à
la campagne heures déjà elle sera suivie
par l'immunologue alain fischer qui est
membre titulaire de l'académie des
sciences est pour le début de cette
campagne deux vaccins sont concernés
dont on connaissait déjà les noms bioen
taquet moderna il devrait recevoir
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
d'ici la fin décembre
qui pour jean castex cette rapidité
n'est pas précipitations au lait coûte
d'optimisme est renforcée par le
lancement très prochain de la campagne
de vaccination contre la copie de 19
l'arrivée du vaccin est une étape très
importante dans notre combat collectif
contre l'épidémie c'est une arme
supplémentaire à notre disposition qui
va nous permettre de mieux nous protéger
la mobilisation exceptionnelle de tous
les acteurs français et mondiaux de la
science et de la recherche médicale a
permis de développer ses premiers
vaccins dans des délais rapides ce qui
nous permettra d'entamer la campagne de
vaccination environ un an après
l'apparition du virus
ce vaccin se fera en injection
intramusculaire pas gratuit mais non
obligatoire et la france va se doter de
200 millions de doses de quoi vacciner
100 millions de citoyens c'est plus que
les besoins
mais on comprend pour le gouvernement il
ne s'agit pas de réitérer des situations
de pénurie comme on en a connu durant la
première vague je parle évidemment des
masques et des tests alors katia
évidemment la question que tout le monde
se pose comment cela va se passer
concrètement alors justement oui la
campagne s'échelonne en trois phases
dans la première elle est destinée à des
publics prioritaires donc les résidents
des ehpad et le personnel soignant et
qui s'occupe d'eux il s'agit tout de
même d'un million de personnes ensuite
la seconde phase à partir de février
d'autres publics prioritaires les
personnes de plus de 75 ans et les
personnes du personnel soignant pardon
de plus de 50 ans et cela représente 14
millions de personnes
la phase iii au printemps et celle de la
campagne au grand public et les
personnes de 50 à 64 ans ainsi que les
employés des secteurs essentiels les
personnes précaires les personnes
vulnérables et le reste bien sûr et bien
la population majeure un se fera
vacciner au fil du temps dans cette
troisième phase il s'agit de la campagne
de vaccination massive pour la réaliser
il y aura donc des circuits logistiques
qui seront mises en place ainsi qu'une
évaluation des personnes vaccinées dans
une démarche de pharmacovigilance merci
katia technique en direct de l'avenue de
ségur ministère de la santé dont ok
alors que le début de la vaccination est
désormais une question de semaines comme
l'a promis le premier ministre le
gouvernement s'est voulu rassurant et
confiant
afin que le plus grand nombre de
français soient vaccinés alors sous
quels auspices présente cette stratégie
vaccinale les conditions sont elles
réunies pour qu'elle soit efficace place
à notre décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois billets lesage pédiatre membres
du groupe de vaccinologie infovac
bonsoir fabrice di vizio avocats de
nombreux soignants notamment dans cette
crise du coc vide bonsoir fabrice di
vizio merci d'être avec nous également
paul thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france qui
demain nous parler de la partie plus
européenne de ces vaccins puisque le
royaume uni a donné son feu vert à la
vaccination
bonsoir à tous les trois merci d'être
avec nous donc on a entendu une
stratégie dévoilée 1 ce soir par le
premier ministre un exercice de
communication qui se présente comme
anticipé réfléchit on ne veut pas
commettre les mêmes erreurs que par le
passé fabrice di vizio
vous l'aurez tous dit un exercice de
communication
voilà nous avons assisté encore et
toujours à un exercice de communication
depuis le départ dans cette crise nous
assistons à des exercices de
communication alors peut-être qu'un jour
il fera autre chose communiqué mais
c'est pas pour tout de suite
et le problème est effectivement
toujours le même c'est que nous
communiquons à tort et à travers et dans
cette affaire de vaccination si
l'objectif est d'emporter l'adhésion de
la population
bah c'est mal parti vous le le défenseur
des vaccins françois vivier lesage vous
avez trouvé cet exercice alors certes de
communication mais quand même avec du
fond est indispensable et plutôt bien
mené par le premier ministre aujourd'hui
et ses ministres
plutôt bien d'ailleurs c'est un exercice
de communication parce que c'est
certainement la plus importante des
choses à faire actuellement
alors je me félicite déjà d'une première
chose c'est que ça soit alain fischer
qui qu'ils étaient
désigné pour diriger cela car il fait
l'unanimité dans les milieux médicaux et
scientifiques c'est un grand un grand
scientifique qui a beaucoup travaillé
sur les problèmes d'immunité de l'enfant
et sur les déficits immunitaires
il a mené aussi la concertation
citoyenne sur la politique vaccinale en
et c'est un homme très compétent et qui
a une éthique absolument irréprochable
il va falloir alors je vois fabrice di
vizio qui est qui qui dit non de la tête
fabrice di vizio vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec cette analyse de françois
billets lesage sur le nouveau monsieur
vaccins non mais je connais pas monsieur
max ans et je m'en fiche en fait je m'en
fiche complètement
je croyais qu'on avait un conseil
scientifique le conseil scientifique
illégaux dans cette affaire
je comprends pas combien de temps nous
allons continuer à mettre des strates
les unes sur les autres dans cette
affaire je veux dire nous avons un
premier ministre et un président de la
république nord ministre de la santé a
fait ce qu'on en a encore un c'est pas
sûr on a un directeur de nsn a lancé mme
en a plus d'ailleurs on a effectivement
un conseil scientifique
ah bah non apparemment non plus pire à
un moment si vous voulez moi je trouve
ça incroyable qu'on se réjouissent du
fait que c'est un exercice de
communication
n'avez-vous donc pas compris à quel
point est-ce qu'on est déconnecté dans
ce pays qu'on n'a plus confiance dans un
gouvernement on n'a plus confiance
vous avez vu effectivement ce qui s'est
passé avec leur ai dit j lire vous avez
vu les couacs monumentaux que ça a
généré vous avez vu les problématiques
autour du masque on nous a menti pendant
des mois et aujourd'hui vous avez raison
c'est un acte majeur la vaccination mais
c'est parce que c'est un acte majeur
qu'il faut effectivement prendre le
temps et ne pas se précipiter et dans
cette affaire on nous explique que c'est
un acte réfléchi mais rien n'est
réfléchi dans cette crise et le brame
rien dire à nos enfants fabrice di vizio
on en parlera d'ailleurs avec pale
thompson dans dans quelques instants on
n'est pas les plus rapides je vous
rassure tout de suite françois vivier
lesage nous disait voilà un exercice de
communication indispensable peut-être
parce que nous sommes les français parmi
les plus sceptiques un an selon un
sondage exclusif ifop fiducial pour ses
news et puis et sud radio une large
majorité de français 1 61%
non pas du tout l'intention de se faire
vacciner contre le coran navires us vous
propose d'écouter justement le ministre
de la santé tout à l'heure olivier
ferrand qui commence déjà essayé de
convaincre les
français et les rassurer une chose est
sûre c'est que la peur du vaccin
n'arrêtera pas le virus ni celui ci ni
les autres nous nous appuierons donc sur
des agences sanitaires indépendante dont
c'est le métier dans ce sont les
fonctions l'émission dans la durée pour
qu'elles s'assurent que nous puissions
vacciner dans de bonnes conditions et
comme l'a dit premier ministre notre
rôle c'est de mettre à disposition le
bon vaccin au bon patient au bon moment
la prudence et l'objectivité doivent
donc que nous guider temps dans le
déploiement dans le déploiement
progressif de la vaccination que dans le
suivi que nous organiserons françois
vivier le sache c'est vraiment ce qu'on
aime tant
parmi les défenseurs du vaccin y en a
même beaucoup évidemment parmi les
scientifiques la plupart il faut cet
exercice de pédagogie indispensable la
part du gouvernement ce virage n'est pas
rater mais il y parlera t il est raté
plus ou moins quand on fait une
communication il ya celui qui parle est
celui qui écoute bouche je suis pas là
pour faire de la polémique avec un
avocat qui à mon avis d un parti pris et
n'est pas là pour savoir comment il va
falloir faire avancer les choses
moi je suis là en tant que scientifiques
et médecins confrontés au vide pour
l'instant directement alors je suis
pédiatre donc je suis pas forcément le
plus confrontés puisque c'est surtout
les ehpad qui sont ce qu'ils sont que
sont confrontées les personnes âgées
dont je suis il est important il ya une
urgence sanitaire il ya une urgence
médicale
nous en tant que scientifique aux
analyses sont les débats nous nous
contentons pas d'analyser les
communiqués de presse savoir quelle est
l'utilisation politique où il est
idéologique qui en est faite
ce qui est important pour nous c'est
d'avoir des données alors les données je
vous rappelle qu'un vaccin en général
ces cinq à dix ans pour être mieux pour
être développées ici
les scientifiques ont eu moins d'un an
et
quel que soit d'ailleurs les pays où ça
a été fait depuis la chine jusqu'aux
états unis en passant par l'europe et
les anglais il ya eu un mouvement
scientifique absolument extraordinaire
je suis pas là pour des formes de
gouvernement
excusez-moi de ceux de vision mais c'est
pas mon sujet je suis pas là dans la
polémique je la hais ce que les vaccins
sont efficaces est-ce que les vaccins
vont être utiles à qui faut-il les faire
je pense que c'est ça le problème
principal je pense que c'est là dessus
que nous travaillons nous et s'ils
voulaient qu'on en discute on discute
mais je pense bat sur les manières de
discuter du gouvernement parle comme ça
mais juste une petite question vous
l'anglais à paris vous êtes étonnés de
ce scepticisme très français parce qu'on
a vu que les britanniques eux on en
reparlera plus en détails après du cas
du royaume-uni mais les britanniques
étaient ravis d'avoir ce vaccin pour la
plupart et coraux se faire vacciner
c'est un débat qui se trouvent dans
nombreux pays en allemagne aux états
unis en angleterre aussi donc je pense
que si j'avais cité un pourcentage à
propos du scepticisme des des français
qui est peut-être plus élevé que dans
d'autres pays
naissent deux phénomènes en lui même
n'est pas exclusivement français loin de
là ils existent aussi en angleterre tant
qu'homme je pense que je ne suis pas du
tout aussi scientifique moi même am je
suppose que cela repose sur fait il y a
eu un cas après dix ans d'une à vaccin
qui a fait quelques dégâts
et pour ceux qui ne sont pas de
formation scientifique dont je suis
encore une fois ça peut inspirer une
certaine crainte ou d'étude en ce qui me
concerne je préférerais à me faire
vacciner sans un instant d'hésitation
mais pense à ça n'engage que moi même
pour récapituler ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui était unique à la france ça ne
ment pas fabrice division sans bouillir
ans qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'ai une question à poser à votre invité
est effectivement qui n'est pas là pour
défendre le gouvernement mais un peu
quand même inquiet de savoir est-ce que
effectivement monsieur vous avez vu les
études sur le vaccin ça m'intéresse
beaucoup de le savoir est ce que vous
pouvez ce soir certifié aux français que
ce vaccin dont vous avez vu les études
vous êtes médecin vous êtes donc un
spécialiste des vaccins parce que c'est
en cette qualité que vous exprimer je
dirais donc avec vous effectivement
contrairement à éric comme qui lui n'a
vu que les communiqués de presse
contrairement à catherine hill qui
manifestement ne les a pas vu non plus
contrairement au conseil scientifique
est ce que vous ce soir vous pouvez dire
aux français sur une chaîne oui mais
j'ai ouï français à 60 millions de
français vous pouvez vous lui avec 6
décembre
je prends la responsabilité personnelle
des études en qualité de médecin je les
ai vus je les ai vu un
parce qu'à un moment donné il faut aussi
assumer je les ai vus mois kerry comme
neda pas vu mais moi je les ai vus et à
ce titre je vous dis eh bien
effectivement tout ça est parfaitement
cadré c'est simple comme question bon je
les aimais bien sûr c'est un avocat qui
va beaucoup mieux que moi le foot vous
connaissez pas très bien le dé la
démarche scientifique je pense ainsi la
première première chose c'est d'avoir
des études scientifiques que nous
attendons je n'hésite pas non mais je
téléphone s'il vous plaît je vous
réponds à votre question non je ne peux
pas d'abaisser leur répondez vous
velud avait voilà la phrase est une
question il var est mon sang froid dans
un tribunal monsieur je suis là j'essaie
d'aider l'a arrêté à régler tant à part
ma petite personne
la crise qu'ont en commun concours donc
là l'évolution sciences de voix qu'on
peut pas vraiment pas discuter avec
monsieur donc le délicieux goûter ainsi
les noms sa prévision n'est pas un
tribunal chacun est là pour donner son
avis non mais s'il se plaît on va donner
chacun son avis très calmement six 6
mois ça m'intéresse
françois biais lesage votre avis
on vous laisse répondre sereinement s'il
vous plaît donc ma réponse serait né
très est très claire c'est non à l'heure
actuelle nous n'avons pas les données
scientifiques complètes qui permettent
d'avoir un avis complet ce qu'il ya
c'est que ça s'est fait très rapidement
nous n'avons pour l'instant que des
communiqués de presse avec quelques
résultats qui sont encourageants mais
sur lequel nous n'avons pas toutes les
données
ces données vont être données suivant un
parcours normal aux agences de santé
qu'elle soit européenne cependant que
lala lala sociale afin de le lemming et
la société du médicament européen
l'achat est ce aussi et ça a été donnée
très certainement un hs anglais aussi
qu'ils vont avoir des dossiers les
dossiers de ce qu'on appelle des mêmes
motorisations de mission de marché qui
ont qui ont des procédures d'urgence
vont être données à ces à ses agences
officielles qui vont les étudier en
détail je peux vous dire que c'est des
très très grosse somme très gros
dossiers qui vont être étudiées
l'autorisation ne sera remis qu'à partir
de là nous nous attendons probablement
mi décembre d'avoir les articles publié
des articles publiés mais même quand
nous aurons les données de ces articles
à les dossiers qui seront dans les
agents seront beaucoup plus importantes
donc on ne va pas mettre le gouvernement
va pas mettre sur le marché des vaccins
comme ça qu'ils n'auront pas été testés
maintenant ça sera de toute façon une
efficacité à court terme pour l'instant
faut pas oublier c'est monsieur cet
avocat qui a l'air d'oublier que le
vaccin à 2 2 deux objectifs à l'intérêt
individuel et un intérêt collectif dans
l'urgence et l'intérêt individuel c'est
à dire ce sont des personnes âgées qui
sont dans les ehpad dont la mortalité
est très importante avec cette maladie
qui doivent être vaccinés en urgence et
c'est pour ça que là ce qui compte c'est
une efficacité à court terme
on a déjà des satisfactions pour les
protéger ces gens là dans un deuxième
temps il faudra voir l'intérêt collectif
c'est à dire le fait d'essayer de
juguler cette pandémie cette épidémie en
vaccinant au moins 50 60 pour savoir la
population avec d'autres vaccins
possiblement moins cher et qui ont
d'autres efficacité on attend d'avoir
les données mais
ni moi ni personne ni monsieur fisher
d'ailleurs ne sont capables pour
l'instant de donner des réponses
précises mais les données vont arriver
dans les quinze jours
mais si notre avocat a préféré ce soir à
toutes les données là dessus et c'est
qu'il ne faut pas vacciner que les gens
peuvent continuer à mourir dans les
hôpitaux
pas très bon on va donner l'accès
ralenti à paul thompson qui est calé au
milieu voilà monsieur division pardonnez
moi quand même des choses sont
suffisamment graves pour que je vous ai
fait pas partie de la sorte jamais
monsieur vient vous expliquer
techniquement pour sa part qu'il n'a pas
les données et c'est légitime et c'est
honnête de le reconnaître
alors effectivement des excusez moi mais
interpellé des gens qui se posent des
questions
de la sorte c'est juste malhonnête mais
c'est pas grave alors paul thompson vous
en angleterre au royaume-uni 1 c'est la
fin du confinement et l'annoncent du
vexin c'était un peu l'euphorie
hier l agence de santé britannique a on
est dans le sujet dit elle avoir
respecté à la lettre les mêmes normes
que l'union européenne pour autoriser le
vaccin est ce que vous en savez plus
justement sur les raisons pour laquelle
c'est aller beaucoup plus vite
en grande bretagne ce que j'ai lu dans
la presse parce qu'encore une fois je ne
suis pas un expert en la matière c'est
que il y avait deux facteurs qui ont pu
permettre l'aboutissement rapide d'une
part l'exécutif a damné à l'exécutif
politique j'entends à donner une
impulsion politique pour que ce soit
fait très rapidement et deuxièmement les
apparemment dans la façon de travailler
des équipes impliquées au royaume uni il
ya une âme et briques à sion volontaire
des différentes étapes donc l'étape 2
lancers pendant que l'étape une toujours
en cours mais on a une intègre au fur et
à mesure des résultats de l'état qu'il
faut dans l'étape 2 et ainsi de suite et
apparemment cette façon de procéder qui
n'est pas utilisée aux états unis par
exemple où il est à noter étanchéité
entre les états d'après ce que j'ai lu
un permettent d'accélérer sensiblement
serait une explication alors il ya une
autre explication c'est celle de matt
ngoc le ministre de la santé qui s'étale
et laisser enfin qui sait qui c'est
c'est plutôt aller à dire que c'était un
petit peu de grâce au break si je vous
propose d'écouter matin coque grâce au
breakbeat nous avons pu prendre une
décision fondée sur le régulateur
britannique un régulateur de classe
mondiale et non au rythme des européens
qui avance un peu plus lentement un
françois biais lesage ça vous inspire
quoi ce genre de réflexion on a subi une
forme de poids de l'administration
européenne dans dans cette affaire des
vaccins c'est pas le premier à le dire
en effectivement voilà je ne parle pas
en tant que journaliste politique au
niveau scientifique si vous voulez les
anglais ont toujours été plutôt en
avance au niveau stratégie politique
vaccinale ils ont souvent souvent
démarré dès des politiques de
vaccination par exemple sur les
méningites à méningocoques bien avant le
reste de l'europe et donc de ce côté là
en particulier le centre d'oxford qui
travaillaient que astrazeneca sûr
toujours en point au niveau de la
recherche ce que dit notre ami anglais
c'est que c'est vrai mais c'est vrai un
peu partout c'est à dire que les phases
de développement des vaccins ont été
forcément raccourci est souvent
chevauchée puisque ben on n'avait pas 5
à 10 ans pour le développer c'est ce
qu'on avait déjà eu on a déjà eu cette
expérience avec le vaccin ebola ce que
j'en ai lu mais pareil jeu là je sais
moi qui ne suis pas du tout un expert en
politique anglaise c'est que je crois
que le premier ministre anglais a été
démentie par la directrice de la deûle
agence l' agence du médicament anglaise
parce que en fait
les lois du break si des lois de
européenne s'applique jusqu'au 1er
janvier mais c'est pas ma spécialité je
veux pas rentrer là dedans et que donc
ça changeait pas grand chose avec la loi
européenne il pouvait tout à fait faire
ce qu'ils ont fait alors est ce que en
plus de donner c'est ça qui m'intéresse
pour démarrer plus vite cette
vaccination
honnêtement ça je ne sais pas donc quand
je ne sais pas je dis que je ne sais pas
durant ce temps mais vous avez raison
mais en l'occurrence c'est vrai qu'on
parle beaucoup c'est pas le seul à le
pdg de moderna l'avait évoquée renaud
muselier d'ailleurs aussi le poids de
l'administration en europe qui fait que
parfois les autorisations sont plus
difficiles à obtenir fabrice di vizio
c'est plutôt une une bonne chose que les
autorisations soient difficiles à
obtenir
parce qu'il faut afficher de la prudence
vous le disiez depuis le début' débat
avec beaucoup de d'entrain des mois mais
vous vivez pas dans le monde m'aime je
suis désolé messieurs dames mais vous ne
vivez pas dans le même monde que moi
donc je ne peux pas mourir css qui
enfile dilettante et c'est très bien ben
non mais vous ne vivez pas nommément que
moi parce que moi j'ai une agence
européenne à qui je reproche
effectivement de s'asseoir sur les
données de sécurité
le renne dibir en est un bon exemple on
a acheté des lots des lots et des lots
de raismes désir alors qu'effectivement
on savait on savait au moment où ça a
été acheté que c'était pas efficace 4 il
ya quelqu'un qui a une lacombe devant la
commission denquête l'avait dit donc ce
que karine la conque savez l'agencé
européenne du médicament ne savais pas
manifestement la france ne le savait pas
non plus au travers de la tpu donné et
aujourd'hui effectivement vous
m'expliquer que tout ça c'est quand même
très ralentie l'agencé européenne du
médicament
finalement prend son temps et monsieur
nous explique effectivement que quand il
ne sait pas il dit qu'il ne sait pas
mais il vous explique quand même qu'il
ne sait rien mais qu'il dit tout et que
sur les vaccins pour l'instant pas
concrètement il ne sait rien il n'a pas
les données mais que nul doute que quand
ce sera dès que ce sera le tour de
vacciner on les aura il ya plus qu elle
espérait paul thompson ça nous inspire
quoi ce genre de débats très français
c'est vrai qu'il ya une défiance envers
les autorités un particulièrement en
france en ce moment
vous constatez la même chose ou comme
dit fabrice division finalement on est
sur une autre planète réunis il y adeux
des vents très violents mais sur des
sujets économiques les anglais sont
obsédés par de vie économique comme
chacun sait est à et donc il ya des
débats même à l'intérieur du parti
conservateur eut à l'inter et famille
mais les intellectuels plutôt du centre
et de la droite il y à de violentes
bagarres à sur des questions
d'importance aux roms la bonne voie a
trouvé entre du à bien protéger les
citoyens et d'autre part ne pas casser
la vie économique
est ce que j'en déduis très simplement
c'est que cette cette pandémie intex
exogènes pour tout le monde ça crée une
stress quasi universelle qui chacun la
vie de sa propre façon mais ce ce stress
se dégage de différentes manières dans
différentes pays différents contextes
mais je pense que cette fois il faut pas
trop s'en émouvoir qu'il ya des
désaccords et que c'est que ce désaccord
peut prendre une tonalité un peu vive
parce que le sujet en lui même est
extrêmement important et concerne
seulement et est donc on se sent tous
concernés et un peu désemparés en même
temps parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'inconnues effectivement et donc
j'attends bataille comme il peut pour
essayer d'y voir clair je vois mon petit
commentaire son ascendant sur votre
question on va terminer sur cette parole
d'apaisement en tout cas voilà les
opinions étaient toutes présentes sur ce
plateau merci beaucoup françois vie
lesage fabrice di vizio également et
paul thompson d'avoir été avec nous pour
commenter notamment cette allocution du
premier ministre qui a lancé présenté sa
stratégie de campagne de vaccination
merci à tous les trois restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
valéry giscard d'estaing décédé hier des
suites du coc vide le président aura
marqué la vème république par son
engagement résolument pro européens mais
aussi par sa politique en afrique
et puis nous parlerons de l'otan un
groupe d'experts recommande dans un
rapport de renforcer la cohésion interne
de l'alliance et de prendre en compte la
montée en puissance de la chine
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qui va là c'est fini pour moi
est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça dit malheur
mais quel est le rapport avec la radical
à sion mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
que s'est il passé entre juillet dernier
la mi novembre pour que la hongrie puis
la pologne
tous deux soutenus par la slovénie des
sites d'apposer leur veto au plan de
relance de l'union européenne les
européens ont décidé de mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle une clause de
conditionnalité c'est à dire ils
conditionnent ce versement
comme respect de certaines mesures de
l'état de droit c'est l'europe qui dit
nous allons décider pour vous et nous
allons nous immiscer on ne va avoir une
juridiction en fait plus haute que les
vôtres ils sont anti européen de tout le
monde at c'est bien connu et donc ils
sont dans une posture aussi je pense que
ils vont très rapidement cédé sur ces
points là parce qu'ils ont besoin de cet
argent pour qu'ils disent non alors que
c'est les principaux bénéficiaires de ce
plan de relance
ça peut bien dire qu'il ya un vrai souci
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le bond de change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée de la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
c'est ça la récré au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement en énerver
grenelle sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours moins de
ceux qui les dirigent
ma journée à mâcon et passe un tour deux
tracteurs et cnooc est en campagne il
faut savoir c'est qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait aider un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
20h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france emmanuel macron a reporté à
demain l'interview médias brut prévue
aujourd'hui
comme pour le décès de jacques chirac le
chef de l'état à nos matchs télévisés
son prédécesseur valéry giscard
d'estaing
emmanuel macron qui décrète un jour de
deuil national mercredi 9 décembre l'ex
président de la république décédé hier à
94 ans des suites du coc vide entouré de
ses proches dans le loir et cher
les réactions des parlementaires
aujourd'hui étaient nombreuses je
retiens de lui son extrême courtoisie sa
très grande capacité d'écouté et sa
volonté de toujours s'intéresser de très
près à ce que ses interlocuteurs
ça faisait ce qu'il avait en face de lui
avec un mini jeu retiennent tout d'abord
que c'était un grand européen européen
commun que la même vue lors du
référendum on entre ou en effet il a pu
à nouveau défendre ses positions
européennes et je crois que c'était un
novateur la de là dessus il
il ya les relations avec avec
l'allemagne très importante et je crois
que l'amitié franco-allemande eux c'est
vraiment nourrit aussi avec ce président
valéry giscard d'estaing
on a effectivement de très grandes
avancées
durant son septennat je pense pas moins
à l'abaissement
à 18 ans je pense notamment à son combat
qu'il a mené avec simone veil pour le
droit à l'avortement dans d'autres
combats qu'il a menés aussi je pense
notamment au divorce par consentement
mutuel non tout ceci ce sont aussi des
faits marquants du septennat de valéry
giscard d'estaing et nombreuses
réactions de la classe politique
française on vient de le voir à
l'international également le premier
ministre britannique boris johnson
évoque un goran derny thater de la
france et d'après la chancelière
allemande angela merkel
berlin jeu si tu perds un ami retour sur
ce septennat de valéry giscard d'estaing
avec meet in romania
je pensais qu'il est le premier
président non gaullistes de la vème
république
né en 1926 valéry giscard d'estaing
accède à l'elysée en 1974 en battant
françois mitterrand à 48 ans il devient
à l'époque le plus jeune président que
la france ait connu depuis 1895 le
polytechnicien et énarque se veut alors
l'incarnation d'une modernité
il fait voter entre autres l'abaissement
de la majorité à 18 ans et la
dépénalisation de l'avortement mais il
mène aussi une politique économique de
rigueur à la fin des trente glorieuses
en 1981 il perd son second duel face à
françois mitterrand la construction
européenne prend alors une place majeure
dans sa vie politique député européen de
1989 à 1993 il est aussi président en
2001 de la convention pour l'europe
chargé de rédiger la constitution qui
sera rejetée par référendum quatre ans
plus tard il ne cessera de vrais à
l'international comme sur ces images où
il rencontre le président russe vladimir
poutine en 2015 sur la situation en
ukraine
sa carrière politique est aussi local il
dirige la région auvergne pendant 18 ans
à partir de 1986 en 2004 il se retire de
la vie politique pour siéger au conseil
constitutionnel l'année précédente il
est élu à l'académie française
la carrière de valéry giscard d'estaing
est aussi marquée par plusieurs affaires
la plus connue révélé en 1979 est celle
dite des diamants de bokassa
d'après le canard enchaîné il aurait
reçu des diamants de la part de l'ancien
empereur de centrafrique alors qu'il
était ministre des finances en 1973 le
dernier scandale en date remonte à mai
dernier il est visé par une enquête pour
agressions sexuelles
après la plainte d'une journaliste
allemande l'ancien chef d'état a fait
l'une de ses dernières apparitions
publiques le 30 septembre 2019 à paris
lors des obsèques d'un autre président
de la république jacques chirac qui
avait été son premier ministre de 1974 à
1976 et pendant les sept ans de son
mandat valéry giscard d'estaing a porté
une attention toute particulière au
continent africain une diplomatie
contesté car jugé trop interventionniste
il a également longtemps été reproché à
l'ancien président ses liens avec les
dirigeants africains controversé c'est
d'ailleurs en partie ce qui a conduit à
sa défaite en 1981 thomas bonne et la
relation entre giscard et l'afrique
était parti d'une promesse celle
formulée en 1974 par celui qui était
alors candidat à la présidentielle
valéry giscard d'estaing affirme alors
vouloir je cite donner une nouvelle
impulsion à la coopération entre la
france et les états francophones
d'afrique
comme pour joindre le geste à la parole
une fois élu valéry giscard d'estaing se
rend en algérie nous sommes en 1975 il
s'agit alors du premier déplacement
officiel d'un président français dans le
pays depuis l'indépendance de 1960 deux
aspects historiques souligné dans le
communiqué commun publié par les deux
chefs d'état la qualité la spontanéité
de cet accueil souligne la haute portée
politique que revêt la visite effectuée
pour la première fois par un président
de la république française à l'algérie
indépendante
cette visite au delà des vicissitudes de
l'histoire et des contentieux du passé
constitue une étape décisive et
prometteuse dans la coopération entre
les deux pays
désormais les conditions d'un dialogue
fécond sont réunis pour dégager des
perspectives
à la mesure des potentialités et des
volontés politiques de l'algérie et de
la france
pourtant les promesses de non-ingérence
ont un flic vont se heurter à la réalité
pendant les sept années de son mandat
giscard va faire intervenir l'armée
française à plusieurs reprises sur le
continent africain que ce soit en
mauritanie au zaïre au tchad ou encore
en centrafrique
ce dernier pays est d'ailleurs très
particulier dans l'esprit de giscard
d'abord car il s'y rend régulièrement
notamment pour des parties de chasse et
ce avant même d'être président il y
rencontre au début des années 70
jean-bedel bokassa avec qui il va nouer
une relation amicale le leader
centrafricain va bénéficier de l'appui
du président français pour asseoir son
autorité sur sa population et ce en
dépit des agissements plus que
controversée de celui qui s'est proclamé
empereur du pays
finalement en septembre 1979 bokassa est
renversé par la france quelques jours
plus tard le canard enchaîné publie un
article intitulé quand giscard empochait
les diamants de bokassa giscard tentent
d'opposer un démenti catégorique mais de
nouvelles révélations du canard enchaîné
le conduisent a finalement expliqué en
1981 que ces cadeaux ont été vendus au
profit d'associations caritatives
centrafricaine mais le mal est fait dans
l'opinion et beaucoup d'analystes
politiques affirment que la défaite du
président sortant contre françois
mitterrand s'explique en grande partie
par ce qui reste est connu comme l'
affaire des diamants
contrairement à ses promesses valéry
giscard d'estaing n'aura donc pas permis
la création d'une relation sans
ingérence entre la france et ses
anciennes colonies africaines
il n'a pas rompu avec la françafrique
avec tout ce que cela comporte comme
controverse
il n'est évidemment pas le seul à blâmer
d'autres après lui or on reproduit les
mêmes erreurs
à l'heure actuelle la présence française
sur le continent est toujours contestée
dans plusieurs pays où des
manifestations anti france ont lieu
régulièrement à l'image de la complexe
relations entre paris et alger la
diplomatie française en afrique
développé par giscard dans les années 70
aura été ponctuée de malentendus
et d'affaires politiques et pour en
parler nous sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialise bonsoir adexi merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france peut
être un mot d'abord sur l'homme un
souvenir marquant
peut-être celui de la constitution
européenne dans ces dernières années
puisqu'il a toujours été l'homme de la
construction européenne il a mille euros
sur les rails il a était aussi il a
oeuvré dans le rapprochement franco
allemand avec helmut schmidt donc sans
doute cet engagement là qui marquera
celui de toute une carrière finalement
de ce président français quelle
empreinte laissera à valéry giscard
d'estaing sur l'histoire des relations
franco africaines selon vous on en a
parlé dans le sujet précédent sujet très
bien fait parce qu'effectivement il
était
arrivant au pouvoir une promesse celle
de la rupture avec la françafrique il
avait d'ailleurs évincé jacques foccart
l'homme des années gaulliste de la
françafrique et avait promis une
coopération différentes et de redonner
de l'indépendance aux états africains
réduits durant son mandat 6 intervention
militaire de la france et plusieurs
opérations de déstabilisation de régime
aux comores au bénin ou encore ailleurs
et on voit bien que l'ailier pratiques
sont très rapidement revenu avec de
nombreuses critiques le lien aussi avec
l'afrique du sud régime d'apartheid
là où valéry giscard d'estaing
souhaitait même intensifier la
coopération nucléaire un pour vendre une
centrale à l'afrique du sud
et puis la sphère des diamants bien sûr
avec jean bédel bokassa qu'il a connu
lorsqu'il était ministre des finances et
qui a pourri cette fin de mandat donc
beaucoup de questions sur la façon dont
finalement la promesse n'a pas été tenue
beaucoup de communication ça a été sans
doute un des premiers présidents a
utilisé beaucoup la communication
politique à la fois de la campagne mais
aussi dans sa pratique du pouvoir alors
la politique de giscard en afrique était
à la fois novatrice en rupture avec
charles de gaulle mais aussi ambivalente
complètement ambivalente puisque il
avait d'un côté le discours ce que
disait qu'il était de redonner
l'indépendance des gestes aussi en
afrique du nord et puis la réalité sur
le terrain avec les opérations
extérieures nombreuses et avec des
opérations également de déstabilisation
avec une sorte de reprise de soft power
à la française le français fabien sur
qui était la clé de voûte de ce système
post coloniale mais néanmoins où la
france gardait à liens très serrés avec
ses anciennes colonies
sachant qu'à l'époque l'afrique ne
l'oublions pas été le nouveau territoire
d'affrontements entre l'est et l'ouest
en pleine guerre froide les troupes
cubaines débarquer aussi dans certains
pays et la france se faisait le bras
armé des états unis qu'ils se
désengageaient des théâtres d'opérations
extérieures après l'échec cuisant au
vietnam et c'est d'ailleurs alexis
l'afrique qui a pesé enlisé sur la
présidentielle de
1981 l'image de giscard d'estaing était
entachée à ce moment là complètement
avec cette fameuse affaire des diamants
du dictateur jean-bedel bokassa diam
affaire révélée par le canard enchaîné
où il aurait reçu plusieurs fois des
diamants de plusieurs dizaines de carats
de la main même de jean-bedel bokassa
lors de ces parties de chasse en afrique
parce que valéry giscard d'estaing était
friand de safari et de chasse en afrique
et la à diverses occasions il avait reçu
trois fois plusieurs diamants dont le
montant reste mystérieux malgré
l'annoncé du canard qui se parlaient de
plus d'un million de francs celle là
était contestée le président valéry
giscard d'estaing avait dit qu'il avait
redonné ces diamants dans le cadre des
musées de la présidence ou bien pour des
oeuvres
peut-être que c'est le cas mais
néanmoins il a perdu et ça a pesé lourd
dans sa fin de mandat face à françois
mitterrand en 1981
et beaucoup de questions restent sûr
bien sûr ces diamants et la proximité
avec jean bédel bokassa qui l'a soutenu
jusqu'à la fin sauf quand le responsable
africain a tué plus d'une centaine de
jeunes écoliers et là il est passé du
côté bien sûr de la déstabilisation pour
démettre l'empereur autoproclamé qui
était boccassien alexis poulet un peu
plus communément giscard d'estaing c'est
évidemment le divorce par consentement
mutuel mais aussi l'avortement légalisé
avec simone veil évidemment oui il a
accompagné les changements de société il
a acté la victoire des luttes féministes
donc il a pu faire ces lois là qui était
demandée c'est tout simplement par
l'évolution de la société et aussi par
ses années de lutte
des féministes qui ont obtenu gain de
cause mais c'est être quelqu'un qui
restait quand même sur la razer
puisqu'il n'a pas aboli la peine de mort
il a laissé des condamnés se faire
décapiter les derniers décapité a été
encore sous son mandat il a également
continué de faire de l'homosexualité est
un délit il n'a pas enlevé la loi qui
faisait de l'homosexualité un délice est
arrivé beaucoup plus tard donc
une avancée mais pas un progrès énorme
il était simplement là au bon moment
pour acter de la victoire de certaines
luttes et heureusement il a fait les
lois qui allait avec
c'est aussi ce qui lui donne cette image
de progressistes qu'il a eu à l'époque
puisque c'était le plus jeune président
élu et qu'il avait utilisé les méthodes
qui avait permis à kennedy de se faire
élire il avait même invité des
conseillers de kennedy pour faire sa
campagne et cette communication où il
s'est mis en scène avec la vie privée
l'accordéon il s'invitait à dîner chez
les français tout en cachant la partie
de beaucoup plus luxueuses des safaris
afric'art des chasse en sologne et c'est
lui à l'âge de 48 ans mercy alexis
poulain en direct dont sur rt france
réunis en visioconférence avant-hier et
hier les ministres des états de l'otan
en traiter de la révision du concept
stratégique de l'alliance
une stratégie qui selon un dernier
rapport baptisé hot en 2030 unis pour
une nouvelle ère doit être revue en
particulier vis-à-vis de la russie
les précisions avec notre correspondante
à moscou vers and of man la
confrontation avec la russie est la
seule raison d'être de le temps disait
le chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov
en août le dernier rapport sur la
stratégie de l'alliance jusqu'en 2030
vient de le confirmer en qualifiant la
russie de principale menace jusqu'à la
fin de la décennie
les auteurs du document baptisé hot en
2030 unis pour une nouvelle ère et
affirme que le bloc
atlantis doit être réformée de toute
urgence le rapport stipule que le temps
devrait faire preuve d'assiduité de
solidarité pour faire face un acteur
comme la russie tout en gardant un
esprit ouvert pour un dialogue éventuel
au cas où les autorités russes
choisirait une voix dit plus
constructive
c'est vraiment nul n'ont pas laissé
indifférente la porte parole du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
mariées zakharova minium source
douanière
dany blessy diogo mais nous n'avons
jamais été les idéologues d'une
organisation régionale ou internationale
quelconque faisant bloc et agissant
selon le principe d'amitié contre quel
karine sportif quand vote de rouge en
achetant cas c'est au petit matin
quant à l'expérience de l'otan je tiens
à vous rappeler l'opinion du président
français selon laquelle l'otan était en
état de mort cérébrale après avoir
entendu une telle évaluation du
président d'un pays membres de
l'alliance
on se demande si l'expérience devrait
effectivement être répété haut de gamme
où les bas postale et le secrétaire
général de l'otan jens stoltenberg a
fait savoir que la version finale du
rapport serait présenté au prochain
sommet de l'organisation militaire en
2021 bruxelles la publication du
document intervient après l'appel du
chef de l'alliance à renforcer davantage
la présence des membres de
l'organisation aux frontières de la
russie sur la péninsule de crimée et la
mer noire ainsi que la nécessité
d'accroître leur présence navale dans
les régions bris pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis budapest avec
georgia samueli chercheurs global policy
institute c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jones samueli merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france 1 les mots
très durs de l'otan vers la chine et
envers la russie est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que les relations puissent
changer entre moscou et l'alliance
mais de dos oui et non chercher un
nouveau rôle cela fait déjà plusieurs
années d'ailleurs qu'elle ne recherchait
est le cas elle se tourne maintenant
vers la chine devait toujours utiliser
un langage assez fort envers la russie
et ce langage violent est maintenant
reportée vers la chine
en tout cas l'animosité est de l'otan
restent tournés en majorité vers la
russie
alors va essayer de poursuivre cette
interview dans ce qui est un petit
problème de liaison on espère que la
traductrice va réussir à suivre ça parce
que ça va être un petit peu compliqué
avec ces coupures
la chine en tout cas georges samueli est
prête à engager un dialogue un l'otan
parallèle des 1000 comment expliquer
plus profondément cette hostilité très
profonde envers pékin s'il en étudie
l'histoire de l'entente new
diop le temps trouve de nouveaux ennemis
régulièrement afin de continuer à
justifier son existence
le dernier rada c'était la guerre contre
le terrorisme
l'intervention humanitaire était un
autre aspect de cette justification
le temps n'a pas tout à fait suivi les
cet acte donald trump contre la chine la
chine mène une politique dispense
d'expansion qui commence à être
problématique maintenant pour le temps
malheureusement de gens le savent mais
lyon va devoir interrompre cette
interview
quand un problème de réseau voilà ça ça
arrive merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france pour
vu de l'extérieur ce soir
et dans le reste de l'actualité si
donald trump s'est montré plutôt
virulent envers l'iran sortant même de
l'accord sur le nucléaire
joe biden entend bien le réintégrer
point de départ de futures négociations
avec les iraniens selon le démocrate
lille assaf joe biden bien décidé à
changer la donne
le président élu américain souhaite
engager rapidement de nouvelles
négociations avec l'iran mais uniquement
après le retour des etats-unis dans
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien qui
l'ont quitté avec donald trump en
consultation avec nos alliés et
partenaires nous allons gagner des
négociations et des accords de suivi
pour resserrer allonger les contraintes
nucléaire de l'iran ainsi que pour
aborder le programme de missiles
les etats-unis ont toujours la
possibilité d'annuler les sanctions si
nécessaire éliront le sait joe biden
confirme qu'il fera donc l'exact opposé
de donald trump sur le dossier du
nucléaire iranien
le contexte est tendu il y a deux ans
après le retrait des états unis de
l'accord conclu en 2015 avec téhéran et
l'imposition de sanctions économiques
par le président sortant
l'iran a répliqué en s'affranchissant de
ses obligations notamment sur la
limitation d'uranium enrichi aujourd'hui
nous sommes plus puissant et plus
compétent que jamais en termes d'énergie
nucléaire
nous sommes dans les meilleures
conditions en termes d'installation
le projet de loi ne devrait pas nous
amener à violer la moralité ou à violer
les faits à cause de bataille politico
électoral
je pense qu'il est d'ailleurs trop tôt
pour évoquer les élections de 2021
il faut parler aux gens des faits très
clairement avec des statistiques
de son côté l'union européenne prépare
une réunion des ministres des pays
signataires de l'accord avant noël
l'objectif éviter que l'iran ne devienne
une puissance nucléaire
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur les annonces de
jocaste ex lors de son point presse sur
la gestion du covan le premier ministre
appelle les français à se faire vacciner
un acte altruiste selon lui et puis nous
parlerons de la dette aggravée par la
crise du coc bide alors peut-on on remet
les compteurs à zéro pour mieux repartir
j'accepte air tentera de répondre à
cette question
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario au réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
déco maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être qu est-ce
qui va rester c'est que les films qui
seront de plus en plus fait pour le
cinéma et pas sur les grands réseaux
resteront des objets artistiques godard
qui disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma on lève
les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu' ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du malheur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la densité brut
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la
population qu'elle doit à des porteurs
de causalité une explication mais des
densités un train si l'on dira
d'appartement il ya des chaînes de
contagion dix autres ont à l'intérieur
rassemblement du milieu familial parce
qu on a des familles vivre à trois
générations et c'est tout cet ensemble
de causes qui constitutionnellement un
syndrome en quelque sorte social et dont
le gaullisme est à la fois le révélateur
est malheureusement la cause
déterminante ponctuelles je suis très
frappé entre présentant des sciences
sociales par finalement le progrès
considérables qu'on a fait dans cette
pandémie la mondialisation a pas que des
mauvais côtés en un an on a mis au poids
pratiquement à venir
[Musique]
m
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs qu'on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ce soit réduire
le débat bhl de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que c'est une histoire de vie et
de mort il faut protéger la végétation
faut protéger la faune il faut protéger
notre santé
tout ça c'est lié n'oublions pas que
tous nos problèmes viennent du mépris
qu'on a sur le reste du monde vivant
donc il faut il faut arrêter de laisser
les chasseurs faire leur bêtise et je
suis poli
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le nombre de contaminés au coin de
chaque semaine je pense que le système
des chu est à bout de souffle
si on ne réforme pas dans les prochaines
années laisser un juron racontines notre
des plaintes le gouvernement ait
finalement pris entre deux feux il
s'agit là d'éviter une crise économique
et en même temps d'hésiter à la
propagation du virus à jour et pas être
à la place du gouvernement français en
ce moment car hier que des mauvaises
solutions
ce que des gens comme moi propose en ce
moment c'est que à la fin du confinement
ont testé 60 millions de français
si on continue comme on fait là moi j'ai
un peu peur pour décoincer jusqu'à la
fin janvier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 3 décembre
jean castex appelle les français à se
faire vacciner un acte altruiste la
stratégie française de vaccination
contre le coc vide a été détaillé tout à
l'heure à 18h par le premier ministre
progressif gratuité en trois étapes
la campagne n'est plus qu'une question
de semaines
un million de personnes devraient être
vaccinés dès janvier dans les ehpad ce
sera ensuite le tour des personnes
vulnérables puis le grand public à
partir du printemps
les italiens en rêvent les français
commencent à y penser faudra-t-il un
jour effacer la dette liés aux qu'ovide
alimenté par des plans de relance parra
onic l'endettement public explose à
travers l'europe
en france on approche des 120 % de dette
par rapport au pib
alors peut-on remettre les compteurs à
zéro pour mieux repartir pour l'heure
bercy et la bce s'y refuse
mais pour combien de temps l'économiste
jacques sapir tentera de répondre à
cette question
[Musique]
coup d'envoi à cet après-midi du
contrôle de 76 lieux de culte musulman
soupçonné de séparatisme réunion entre
le ministre de l'intérieur et les préfet
pour hors-jeu site fermé ses mosquées si
les doutes sont confirmés selon gérald
darmanin 18 mo ce qui pourrait être
close très rapidement et 58 autres subir
des contrôles administratives strictes
[Musique]
jean castex a donc tenu une conférence
de presse à 18h sur la stratégie
vaccinale et la lutte contre le coc vide
les précisions avec notre reporter katia
pique nique avenue de ségur jean castex
a donc détaillé les conditions et dates
de la campagne vaccinale mais il a en
début de discours rappelé que le
confinement allait s'achever d'ici deux
semaines des restrictions vont persister
bien sûr il a par exemple conseillé de
n'être que 6 adultes pour les fêtes
sans compter les enfants alors reparlons
de cette campagne de vaccination c'est
alain fischer un immunologue membre
titulaire de l'académie des sciences qui
va la suivre
et puis pour le début de cette campagne
nous aurons à disposition deux vaccins
dont on connaissait les noms celui de
biotech et celui de modern art il
devrait être mis sur le marché aime
recevoir cette autorisation décembre
mais pour jean castex s'être acquitté
n'est pas précipitation ou l'écoutent
cet optimisme est renforcé par le
lancement très prochain de la campagne
de vaccination contre la comique 19
l'arrivée du vaccin est une étape très
importante dans notre combat collectif
contre l'épidémie c'est une arme
supplémentaire à notre disposition qui
va nous permettre de mieux nous protéger
la mobilisation exceptionnelle de tous
les acteurs français et mondiaux de la
science et de la recherche médicale a
permis de développer ses premiers
vaccins dans des délais rapides ce qui
nous permettra d'entamer la campagne de
vaccination environ un an après
l'apparition du virus
ce vaccin se fera en injection
intramusculaire il sera gratuit non
obligatoire et la france va se doter de
200 millions de doses de quoi vacciner
100 millions de citoyens c'est plus que
les besoins de la france mais on sent
bien que le gouvernement n'a pas envie
de réitérer des situations de pénurie
comme on en a connu durant la première
vague je parle évidemment des masques
des tests alors concernant les phases de
la campagne il s'agit de trois phases en
fonction de la vulnérabilité des publics
concernés
la première commencera dès fin décembre
elle
concerne les résidents des ehpad et leur
personnel soignant cela représente un
million deux personnes la seconde phase
concerne les personnes de plus de 75 ans
les soignants de plus de 50 ans et cela
représente 14 millions de personnes
la phase iii au printemps concerne
encore des publics prioritaires qui sont
les personnes de 50 à 64 ans les
personnes qui travaillent dans des
secteurs essentiels des citoyens
vulnérables précaires et ensuite on
passe dans la campagne de vaccination
massive pour tous les majeurs pour la
réaliser cette campagne est bien il y
aura la mise en place de circuits
logistiques et bien sûr une évaluation
des personnes vaccinées dans une
démarche de pharmacovigilance fait une
campagne de dépistage massif aux kobe 19
aura lieu à lille et à saint-etienne
ainsi qu'au havre annonce d' emmanuel
macron hier à l'issue du déjeuner avec
le président du sénat gérard larcher
ainsi que les chefs de groupes
politiques au palais bourbon jean castex
a lui évoqué trois territoires
d'expérimentation le nord la normandie
et l'auvergne rhône-alpes en
privilégiant des zones où il y à pas mal
de population une opération qui devrait
se dérouler avant les fêtes de fin
d'année et sur la base du volontariat
selon le premier ministre
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe froguel chercheur généticien
professeur à l'impérial college de
londres et l université de lille 2 bons
soient enfin un philippe froguel merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france est une campagne de dépistage
massif donc qui s'élance enfin me direz
vous vous qui prenez l'utilisation de
tous les tests à savoir les pcr les
antigénique les c'est l'hiver oui c'est
enfin c'est quand même assez longtemps
que qu'on demande ça enfin le les
pouvoirs publics ont pris une décision
et enfin il se décida à travailler au
plan logistique pour rendre sa possible
possible quand peut-être elle ou après
les fêtes
donc dans trois endroits dont deux qu'il
ya eu un énorme circulation de vie
russe le troisième membre je sais pas
pourquoi ça a été décidé
enfin bon pourquoi pas et donc voilà
maintenant on commence à travailler avec
les pouvoirs publics et au niveau local
pour rendre sa possible et surtout en
tirer des conclusions scientifiques et
médicales pour la suite puisque la suite
c'est d'éviter une troisième vague alors
qu'on a bien vu aujourd'hui que
l'arrivée des vaccins srl lente et très
très progressive
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu faire
cela avant les fêtes alors pour la
plupart ça sera fait avant les fêtes
mais on n'a pas de sentiment que ça soit
vraiment l'objectif à vous venez de le
dire il faut éviter une troisième femme
mais pas forcément ce qui est si des se
sont pas forcément les fêtes de famille
de noël dans le nord par exemple ce sera
certainement après noël ce n'est pas un
petit peu dommage si on avait décidé 3
semaines avant et qu'on avait un plan de
près on aurait pu faire vers la mi
décembre mais là en tout cas dans le
nord ça paraît extrêmement difficile et
puis on a discuté entre nous et on s'est
dit que ce qu'il fallait c'était savoir
après les fêtes et la circulation du
virus qui va accompagner les personnes
où on en est exactement pour prendre les
bonnes mesures
maintenant ça n'empêche pas les
personnes qui vont voyager et voir leurs
parents aux grands parents de se faire
tester notamment les tests antigénique
sommes là pour savoir si ils sont pas
porteurs et protéger ainsi les personnes
qu'ils aiment donc en pas de défi sage
massive on l'a dit pcr ans qui gène ikke
c'est l'hiver vous les mettez tous au
même niveau c'est est-ce alors penser
qu'ils n'ont pas la même efficacité
les tests antigénique en efficacité plus
faibles et en plus il faut des
prélèvements naso-pharyngés legrand
coton tige
nous on aime bien les tests salivaires
qui s'emporte encore autorisée pour les
porteurs sains hélas par la haute
autorité de la santé donc on va utiliser
ces tests grandeur nature dans ces
villes pour démontrer la haute autorité
de santé qu'on peut faire ça comme nous
fait d'ailleurs partout dans le monde
parce que les tests salivaires c'est
beaucoup plus facile l'acceptabilité des
tests salivaires et de l'ordre de 90%
alors qu'elle est plus faible
ailleurs c'est important cette
acceptabilité parce que on aurait testé
tout le monde pas pas simplement une
toute petite fraction de la population
l'objectif vous disiez il faut éviter
une troisième vague
est ce que cette campagne peut-elle
vraiment éviter une troisième vague
parce qu'après évidemment il faut isoler
de manière efficace il faut qu'on essaye
de tout faire pour retarder cette
troisième vague qui si on fait rien
arrivera entre le mois de mars et le
mois de mai c'est à dire un moment où il
y aura très peu de personnes finalement
qu'en ont déjà été vaccinées en tout cas
parmi les gens qui bougent qu'ils
transmettent le virus
et si on arrive à identifier le plus
possible des gens il converse met en
place enfin des mesures d'isolement
correct avec les pouvoirs publics c'est
à dire en fête avec les collectivités
locales les services sociaux
on peut espérer comme dans d'autres pays
qu'on arrive à fortement diminué le
nombre de porteurs et donc espérer que
la troisième vague n'arrivera pas où
arrivera beaucoup plus faiblement et
plus tardivement emmanuel macron a prôné
une contrainte dans l'isolation ces
députés on aime parler d'éventuelles
sanctions vous vous êtes pour vous
pensez que c'est nécessaire je suis je
suis contre toute contrainte que ce soit
pour la vaccination que ce soit pour le
test isolement puisque ça entraîne des
débats à n'en plus finir sur les
libertés et finalement des des activités
contre-productive provocatrice de toute
une partie de la population
je préfère convaincre et dire à beaucoup
de gens que s'ils veulent revivre
normalement retourner au restaurant
aller dans les bars et dans les night
clubs et les gym salle de gym il est
vraiment important qui nous aident à
abaisser le taux de portage du virus
philippe baumel on a suivi tout à
l'heure l'allocution du premier musée
vous disiez les vacances à risque
clairement de prendre du temps combien
de temps vous y croyez vous aux
premières vaccinant vaccination fin
décembre pour les plus âgés en avril
pour la plupart de la population
moi j'ai vu ça comme un effet d'annonce
je pense qu'il y aura très peu de dos
qui vont arriver à la fin de l'année je
le pense aussi qu on pourra au début
janvier février faire effectivement les
ehpad
tant mieux il y aura moins de personnes
qui vont mourir et moins qui se
retrouveront dans les hôpitaux mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde a dit il ya
dans les réanimations et dans les
hôpitaux il ya 40% de de gens qui ont
moins de 50 ans ce qui veut dire que
même s'ils ne meurent pas ils sont
vraiment malades et et si vraiment on
veut s'en sortir il va falloir il aurait
fallu en réalité ce n'est mieux se
débrouiller pour avoir le test files
heures le test moderna que les anglais
vont avoir moi on m'a déjà proposé
imperial college de de me faire vacciner
dans les prochaines semaines mais qu'en
france on sait pas dévoyée pour avoir
rapidement
merci philippe froguel en tout cas
d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france merci
à vous en espagne le gouvernement
dévoilé le plan des restrictions qui
seront mises en place pour la période
des fêtes de léger assouplissement pour
les réunions de famille mais les
déplacements toujours limitée des slits
signe là vous êtes sur place et pas de
grand dîner de noël cette année dix
personnes maximum pour les
rassemblements des fêtes de fin d'année
c'est ce qui a été annoncé
officiellement par le gouvernement
espagnol
alors actuellement les réunions sont
limitées au nombre de six personnes
mais les espagnols pourront donc se
réunir à 10
aucune exception ne sera faite ni pour
noël ni pour nouvel an et le nombre de
disques ont également les enfants alors
du 23 décembre au 6 janvier les
habitants peuvent tout de même quitté
leur région de résidence pour rendre
visite à de la famille ou à des proches
ou pour des besoins essentiels dans le
cas contraire les déplacements hors des
régions ne sont pas autorisés alors le
gouvernement appelle les habitants à
faire très attention la prudence est de
mise
et concernant le couvre-feu dans la nuit
du 24 au 25 décembre et dans la nuit du
31 décembre au 1er janvier
il pourrait être 1h30 maximum mais ce
sont les régions qui auront le dernier
mot alors toutes ces mesures visent à
contenir l'épidémie
en cette période délicate je vous
propose d'écouter le ministre de la
santé salvadori la chaume oujda touche
guaino vannes pied les chiffres actuels
n'incite pas à l'optimisme mais incite à
la prudence
il faut maintenir une attitude de grande
prudence il est vrai que les chiffres
baissent mais de plus en plus lentement
nous sommes encore à 251 cas pour 100000
habitants et notre objectif est
d'arriver à 25
il reste donc encore un long chemin et
j'insiste les chiffres incitent à la
prudence
donne nous sommes là pour les lire le
plan de restriction représente un vrai
défi pour l'espagne car si les chiffres
se stabilise le gouvernement craint une
nouvelle vague de cas de kovy 19 après
les fêtes
les italiens auraient mme les français
commencent à y penser faudra-t-il un
jour effet c est la dette liée aux
qu'ovide alimenté par des plans de
relance pharaonique pour faire face à la
pandémie
l'endettement public explose à travers
l'europe en france on approche des 120 %
de dette par rapport au pib
alors peut-on remettre les compteurs à
zéro pour mieux repartir pour l'heure
bercy et la bce s'y refuse mais pour
combien temps on voit ça tout de suite
avec l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques et voilà jacques le jingle
bonsoir j'ai à coeur
donc cette question à de l'aggravation
de la dette publique
est-ce que c'est sûr gens pour qu'elle
impose à ce point dans saint paul à ce
point justement dans le débat public
alors oui il y a un problème de dette
publique mais il est aussi vrai que l'on
instrumentalise politiquement la dette
publique alors il est évident que la
crise sanitaire et la crise économique
qu'elle engendre ont provoqué dans la
plupart des pays une très forte
augmentation de la dette publique
mais cette dette certains points
d'épouvantail ainsi quand olivier du sol
le ministre des comptes publics ou bruno
le maire le ministre des finances
martèle que cette dette doit être
remboursé qu'elle sera remboursé
évidemment ils prennent une position qui
est plus politique qu'économique car en
réalité il ya de nombreuses manières de
gérer sa tête
alors rappelons tout de suite que en
1946 après la guerre la dette en
pourcentage du pib est bien été bien au
delà des 120 % actuels et pourtant
en 1960 elle était revenue à 35% du pib
il faut donc cesser de faire peur et de
se faire peur avec cette dette publique
et tous s'en servir comme d'un prétexte
ou d'un levier pour des politiques
d'austérité
alors en quoi cet accroissement de la
dette est il sans précédent alors oui il
est clair que la crise sanitaire a
provoqué une très forte montée de la
dette publique dans tous les grands pays
quel qu'ait été leur situation
financière avant 2020
la crise in la crise sanitaire et
l'effondrement économique elles
engendraient ont conduit à une très
forte envolée de la dette publique
les chiffres du fmi que l'on voit sur le
graphique qui résultent destinations qui
ont été faits il faut le souligner avant
la deuxième vague montrent que la dette
devrait connaître un pic à la fin de
l'année si on inclut les effets de la
deuxième vague
il est probable que le pic sera décalée
sur 2021 mais remarquons aussi que cette
envolée n'est pour l'instant pas aussi
forte que celle résultant de la crise
financière de 2008 et remarquons enfin
que le problème sera très sérieux en
italie et il n'est donc pas du tout
étonnant que le débat sur l'annulation
de la dette et commencer là bas mais il
apparaît aussi que des problèmes
similaires
se feront sentir en france en belgique
en espagne et au portugal
alors jacques peut-on mesurer la dette
engendrée par l'épidémie du code vide
oui on peut l'estimer même s'il est
assez difficile de le faire avec
précision là encore si on prend les
estimations qui ont été fournies par le
fonds monétaire international pour 2020
et 2021
on peut en avoir une image mais une
image à minima parce que je me rappelle
ces estimations
elles datent d'avant la deuxième vague
alors qu'est ce qu'on constate dans on
constate effectivement que certains pays
se sont fortement endettés et si l'on
prend justement les six pays qui sont
sur ce graphique et bien on voit que ils
ont accumulé à eux six à peu près 13 150
milliards de dette en deux ans peut-être
un peu plus même bon et que l'union
européenne ou plus exactement la zone
euro accumulera elle environ 2000
milliards de dettes alors pourquoi
parler d'annulation de la dette
la raison en est simple de nombreux
économistes mais aussi des hommes
politiques comme arnaud montebourg
craint que cette dette ou plus
exactement que ce surcroît de dette
engendrée par la crise sanitaire
n'empêche les pays de la zone euro de
redémarrer économiquement le problème
n'est pas nouveau 1 lors de la crise
financière de 2008
la fameuse crise des subprimes la dette
avait aussi explosé la volonté de
certains gouvernements de réduire la
dette dans les années qui ont suivi
immédiatement
cette crise avait fortement limiter la
croissance
cela a été le cas en france avec la
politique menée par le gouvernement
fillon alors un risque réel observé
stéphanie quand on voit que l'on reparle
ainsi de la réforme des retraites
bruno le maire en a parlé au tout
récemment justement à cause de la dette
kovy effectivement on peut le craindre
alors comment faire pour annuler cette
fameuse dette
il y a plusieurs solutions tout d'abord
la banque centrale européenne peut tout
simplement décidé d'acheter la dette
directement aux états alors
que pour l'instant elle ne peut pas le
faire du moins en théorie et conserver
la dette qu'elle a achetés pendant une
longue période ils ont 2 50 à 75 ans
alors mais christine lagarde pour la bce
s'y est refusé non oui effectivement
effectivement c'est fanny qu elle a
déclaré que cela était impensable à
plusieurs reprises et pourtant il faut
savoir que christine lagarde fait tout
ce qui est en son possible pour
maintenir les taux d'intérêt au plus bas
alors est ce que ce n'est pas un peu
contradictoire bien sûr bien sûr on voit
bien que christine lagarde est d'un côté
limitée dans son action par les pays qui
tiennent à une forme d'austérité que ce
soit la finlande l'autriche les pays bas
et surtout à l'allemagne mais que d'un
autre côté elle fait tout ce qu'elle
peut pour que les pays puissent trouver
les liquidités nécessaires
alors y at il d'autres solutions oui
naturellement naturellement stéphanie
les pays de la zone euro par exemple
pourrait décider à l'unanimité de par
exemple d'annuler une partie de leurs
dettes redisons 20% alors on appelle ça
dans l'argot des banquiers un arc qui me
coupe de cheveux cela d'ailleurs il faut
le dire c'est déjà pratiqué pour la
grèce mais il faudrait une par
l'unanimité des pays de la zone euro et
surtout que ce fameux haircut ne soient
pas accompagnés de clauses
contraignantes comme cela a été le cas
pour la grèce en particulier outre man
10 ares une option qui est peu probable
alors on parle aussi de transformer la
dette en dettes perpétuelles
effectivement effectivement et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que l'état
annonce qu'il ne paiera pas le capital
mais qu'il s'engage à payer les intérêts
sur une très longue période
de fait la grande bretagne vient de
racheter il ya quelques mois la dette
perpétuelle qu'elle avait émise pour
financer les guerres napoléoniennes donc
voyez où tout début du 19e siècle
là encore sow signalé qu'il faudrait un
accord de l'ensemble de la zone euro
pour éviter justement que les taux
d'intérêt ne soit trop élevé alors en
conclusion jacques avec toutes ses
limites il
franchement de solutions bien c'est fini
c'est là où l'on mesure effectivement le
problème qui est posé par la rigidité
des institutions européennes et en
particulier de la zone euro des
solutions sont tous n'est d'ailleurs pas
de la même solution soit adaptée à
chaque pays
mais le plus simple reste quand même que
la banque centrale puisse racheter
directement des routes trésor sur une
longue période ont deux trois peut être
quatre années or la banque centrale
européenne ne veut pas du fait de
l'existence de l'euro les banques
centrales nationales elles ne le peuvent
pas et donc il est à craindre que la
question de la dette qui pour l'instant
relativement indolore puisque les taux
d'intérêt sont très bas
bien que cette question de la dette
empoisonne le débat public et
contraignent dramatiquement les
politiques publiques dans un certain
avenir et bien jacou merci pour cet
éclairage et à la semaine prochaine face
à l'augmentation du nombre de cas de
coronavirus la turquie durcit les
restrictions antique au bide
des mesures qui reste insuffisant selon
les médecins du pays qui appellent à des
décisions plus fortes ont fait le point
avec leila sarah changement de méthode
la semaine dernière les autorités
turques ont modifié leur façon de
compter les infections quotidienne
désormais tous les nouveaux cas positifs
sont comptabilisés et plus seulement le
nombre de patients traités pour des
symptômes
résultat plus de 30 mille nouvelles
contaminations par jour la réaction des
autorités n'a pas tardé pendant la
semaine
tous les jours un couvre-feu général
sera mis en place
de 21h à 5h cette restriction se
poursuivra sans interruption
le week end de 21h le vendredi soir à
cinq heures le lundi matin
qu est ce une cuisse le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui confronté au dilemme de
contenir l'épidémie tout en continuant
de préserver l'économie menacée de
récession
les nouvelles mesures ont commencé à
être appliquée dès ce mardi
les personnes de plus de 65 ans et de
moins de 20 ans ne pourront pas utiliser
les transports en commun les prières
funéraires auront lieu avec au plus 30
personnes y compris des parents immédiat
et les mariages ne pourront pas dépasser
ce nombre des doutes subsistent quant à
l'ampleur réelle de la pandémie dans le
pays l'association des médecins de
turquie est convaincu que le nombre de
cas quotidiens
à l'heure actuelle représente le double
du bilan officiel
une situation qui fait désormais de la
turquie l'un des états les plus touchés
d'europe
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des 76 lieux de culte
musulman soupçonné de séparatisme gérald
darmanin a affirmé que les mosquées
seront fermés style des doutes sont
confirmés ce sera l'objet de notre face
à face et puis direction le québec où la
langue française est en déclin c'est ce
que dit le gouvernement de justin
trudeau
[Musique]
que s'est il passé entre juillet dernier
la mi novembre pour que la hongrie puis
la pologne
tous deux sont tenues à part la slovénie
décident d'imposer leur veto au plan de
relance de l'union européenne les
européens ont décidé de mettre en place
ce qu'on appelle une clause de
conditionnalité c'est à dire ils
conditionnent ce versement non respect
de certaines mesures de l'état de droit
c'est l'europe qui dit nous allons
décider pour vous et nous allons nous
immiscer on ne va avoir une juridiction
en fait plus haute que les vôtres ils
sont anti européen de toulon date c'est
bien connu et donc ils sont dans une
posture aussi je pense que ils vont très
rapidement cédé sur ces points là parce
qu'ils ont besoin de cet argent pour
qu'il dise non alors que c'est les
principaux bénéficiaires de ce plan de
relance
ça peut bien dire qu'il ya un vrai souci
quand vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui avec cette deuxième vague
avec ce deuxième au film en est ce qu'on
pouvait faire autrement plus vous
dépister - les gens meurent et ça a été
vu en allemagne quatre fois moins de
morts qu'en france ça a été vu en
autriche 4 fois moins de morts propose a
été vu en corée du sud etc
ça ne profite pas de ce deuxième
confinement pour dépister
systématiquement les choses vont
recommencer
il y aura une troisième vague au
printemps et un troisième confinement il
se paie ni sera évidemment cloués au sol
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on s'en doute il est
clair que tout le monde attend ça est-ce
que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous le numéro i l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens qui
s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelques pas
dans notre politique internationale vis
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement au
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
un des sujets les plus préoccupants du
moment et celui de l'otan et de la
défense ont donné tout au long des
années l'alliance atlantique s'est
investi dans des guerres qui n'étaient
pas toujours réellement en ligne avec
ses objectifs tenu de la situation s'est
aggravée avec le début d' attaques
contre la frégate courbet 10 juillet les
mots n'assure contre la grèce et la
présence de dieu à dist syriens venus
d'idlib haut karabakh
incapable de régler ses conflits
internes le temps est devenu un frein
politique à l'unité européenne
c'est à l'europe d'être en capacité
d'assumer la responsabilité de sa propre
sécurité et d'agir de manière autonome
quand c'est nécessaire mais compte tenu
des divergences avec l europe pourront
nous le faire
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle en 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée de la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une perception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
c'est ça la réinfection dessus du bureau
de chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus si vous nous rejoignez en
direct début cet après midi d'une vaste
opération anti séparatisme visé 76
mosquée selon l'annoncé hier sur twitter
du ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin et ce moins d'une semaine avant
le conseil des ministres examine le
projet de loi comportant les principes
républicains
une action présentée par le gouvernement
comme massive et inédite contre le
séparatisme et minigo gages c'est une
vaste offensive que s'apprête à lancer
gérald darmanin des mosquées vont être
la cible d'une action massive et inédite
le ministre de l'intérieur l'a annoncé
en ces termes ce mercredi conformément à
mes instructions
les services de l'état vont lancer une
action massive et inédite contre le
séparatisme 76 mosquée soupçonnait de
séparatisme vont être contrôlés dans les
prochains jours et celles qui devront
être fermés le seront dans son tweet
gérald darmanin renvoie à un article du
figaro le texte dévoile une note envoyée
aux préfets un document dans lequel le
ministre de l'intérieur donne plus de
détails sur les mosquées se trouvant
dans sa ligne de mire
seize sont situés en région parisienne
les 60 autres dans le reste du pays
parmi ces mosquées 18 sont décrites
comme des cibles prioritaires
certaines qui ont ignoré une première
décision de fermeture se trouve en seine
saint denis
la majorité de ces mosquées dites cibles
prioritaires sont localisés dans le
reste du pays notamment dans l'hérault
le nord et le bas rhin
elles vont être l'objet d'une action
immédiate qui peut aller jusqu'à la
fermeture du lieu de culte
une annonce qui arrive à une semaine du
prochain conseil des ministres
il doit examiner le projet de loi
comportant les principes républicains
qui vise à lutter contre l'islam radical
et les séparatismes
un texte qui sera présenté par gérald
darmanin et sa ministre délégué à la
citoyenneté
marlène schiappa alors question
l'exécutif pousse-t-il vers une vraie
réforme efficace ou fait-il des effets
d'annoncé l'objet de notre face à face
ce soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec saïd bouamama sociologue militants
du front uni des immigrations et des
quartiers populaires bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés eléonore
besse vice présidente du groupe fn
région paca bonsoir madame merci d'être
avec nous également une action massive
donc contre le séparatisme c'est ainsi
que nous la présente gérald darmanin je
vous propose de regarder tout d'abord
conformément à mes instructions les
services de l'état vont lancer une
action massive et inédite contre le
séparatisme 76 mosquée soupçonnait de
séparatisme vont être contrôlés dans les
prochains jours et celles qui devront
être fermés le seront alors le ministre
de l'intérieur de l'intérieur pardon qui
affiche sa fermeté dans les médias sur
les réseaux sociaux effet d'annonce on
s'est vraiment la première fois qu'un
ministre a agi avec efficacité sur cette
question saïda bouamama
on a surtout offert un scénario
parfaitement huilée qui est un scénario
qui vise à détourner les véritables
questions qui se posent dans cette
société
à une semaine du débat sur un nouveau
projet de loi qui comporte des mesures
qui sont extrêmement dangereuses pour
les droits démocratiques
voilà qu'on nous annonce ses enquêtes ou
ses mosquées sont dangereuses et il
fallait dans le passé déjà arrêté leur
fonctionnement ou alors nous avons à
faire une stratégie de communication qui
vise tout simplement à diffuser de la
peur pour légitimer et faire approuver
ce projet ce projet de loi il arrive
d'ailleurs à un moment particulier il ya
un moment où un gouvernement est devant
une crise de légitimité sans précédente
depuis le mouvement des gilet jaune
contre la réforme des retraites du
mouvement contre les crimes racistes on
a un gouvernement qui
a pas cessé de perdre en crédibilité on
a un gouvernement également qui est
confronté aujourd'hui à la contestation
de la loi contre la sécurité globale et
qui ne sait pas comment se dépêtrer de
la situation et qui nous lance un débat
écran un débat qui vise à détourner
l'attention par la peur pour qu'on ne
parle pas des autres questions qui sont
des questions qui travaille la société
française on a à quelque chose qui est
en outre extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'il est pardonnez moi on va faire
réagir tout d'abord eléonore belle
manière de faire diversion selon vous
vous êtes d'accord avec saïd bouamama
pour un gouvernement qui est empêtré
dans sa loi de sécurité globale alors
moi je pense ce n'est pas une manoeuvre
de diversion
c'est plutôt une opération de
communication une énième opération de
communication de plus je le crains
puisque effectivement il faut contrôler
et il faut fermer les lieux de culte
salafistes
on les connaît ils sont recensées il y
en a beaucoup plus que 76 sur le
territoire français et la peur elle
n'est non pas déjà distillé elles
existent puisque vous rappelle le
dernier attentat en date qu'il s'agit
quand même d'une décapitation d'un
professeur la haine et la haine elle est
distillée effectivement dans ces
mosquées par des prêcheurs de haine qui
pour la plupart ne sont pas forcément un
ressortissant du lego sur le territoire
français qui devrait être expulsé il ya
également des fichiers s je crois
qu'aujourd'hui gérald darmanin il va
falloir qu'ils passent des paroles aux
actes
voilà ce que c'est toujours on fera on
va faire on va contrôler on va peut-être
faire mais il va falloir vraiment
effectivement le faire saïd bouamama sur
les 76 mosquée visée y en a 16 en région
parisienne 60 en province il ya vraiment
un vrai sujet sur ces mosquées et si oui
pourquoi elles n'ont pas été tout
simplement fermé avant depuis le temps
qu'on en parle gouvernement après un
gouvernement
tout simplement parce que on a là un
thème qui est un thème extrêmement utile
pour tous les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé à chaque fois qu'ils ont eu
besoin de détourner l'attention
autrement dit il n'ya pas deux
montée réelle de lutter contre ceux qui
utilisent l'islam où certaines mosquées
ou lieux de culte à des fins de
diffusion d'une idéologie fanatique mais
il y a par contre une accusation
permanente de l'ensemble des musulmans
soit de manière explicite soit de
manière implicite et par conséquent ce
thème il on en a besoin à chaque fois
qu'on veut détourner l'attention vous
dites il ya une réelle volonté de lutter
c'est ce que vous me dites absolument
n'y a pas de volonté lutter si on
voulait vraiment voir lutter contre le
terrorisme aujourd'hui on ne le ferait
pas en stigmatisant
on n'aura pas de lutte contre le
terrorisme dans ce pays sans les
musulmans ou encore mois contre les
musulmans et donc la question qui est
posée c'est pour lutter réellement
contre le terrorisme quel type de
politique que doit-on mettre en place
est ce que c'est une des politiques qui
amalgame des politiques les stigmatise
des politiques qui font agité les médias
en permanence sur les questions du
danger de l'islam des musulmans etc
et tant qu'on en sera là et bien on aura
aucune prise sur malheureusement le
terreau qui est qui qui entretient le
terrorisme et dernière chose
aucune de ces lois qui sont mis en avant
en permanence ne pose la question des
causes qu est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
des jeunes puissent être attiré vers ce
type d'attentât qu'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on ait eu ce type
d'attentats si on ne pose pas la
question des causes travailler
uniquement sur la peur ne conduira qu'à
clivé encore plus la société est donc à
entretenir et bien les dangers de
clivages et les honneurs baisse vous
êtes d'accord avec ce diagnostic c'est
une en amalgame une stigmatisation de
tous les musulmans de s'attaquer à ces
mosquées qui nous sont présentés comme
fanatiques
pas du tout après vous savez les
attentats qui ont été commis qui ont été
commis en france depuis 2015 il y en a
eu et même dans les années auparavant
les décennies précédentes les attentats
depuis 2000 15 depuis charlie hebdo ont
tous été commis par des par des
fanatiques islamistes ça voilà c'est un
fait incontestable
il n'y a pas par contre ça veut pas dire
que tous les musulmans sont des
terroristes
absolument pas mais tous les terroristes
était effectivement des musulmans donc
il n'ya pas n'y a pas d'amalgamé n'y a
pas de séparation il n'y a pas de
clivage aujourd'hui qui crée la
séparation
eh bien ce sont les islamistes qui crée
cette séparation
ce sont eux qui la créent dans ces
mosquées et il y en a encore une fois
bien plus que 76 parce qu'il ya rien que
sur le territoire il ya au moins 200
mosquées contrôlé par les frères
musulmans qui sont qui est par lui au
lièvre qui est une émanation des frères
musulmans il ya les mosquées également
qu'ils sont contrôlés par le tabligh qui
lui est autre chose encore que le
séparatisme que là on est vraiment très
très loin de delà de la deûle à delà du
respect de la république française
notamment à lunel parce que vous avez
cité le département de l'hérault à lunel
gars deux mosquées d'où sont partis six
familles jihadistes vous avez à
marseille aussi la mosquée des bleuets
vous avez vous avez la mosquée aussi du
marché aux puces qui sont des mosquées
qui sont proches des frères musulmans
qui devraient être contrôlés en tout cas
qui devrait être déjà ou des actions
devraient être menées
puisque il ya eu déjà des enquêtes du
sénat
il ya déjà eu des on les connaît ces
terroristes on sait qu'ils quittent ils
sont sur le territoire français parce
que au final après toutes les enquêtes
on sait ont ils ont été tous piste et
ils ont tous été détectés donc ils sont
connus et ce qui est ce qui est ce qui
aujourd'hui est en effet d'annoncer
qu'aujourd'hui on nous dit on va les
contrôler alors qu'on aurait dû le faire
bien en amont bien avant pour éviter
pour éviter le carnage qu'on a qu'on est
en train de subir en tout cas clairement
les tentes est en pleine offensive
opération d'envergure contre ces mosquée
radicale dissolution officielle hier en
conseil des ministres du ccf 1 le comité
contre l'islamophobie est une
association présentée comme ennemis de
la république par gérald darmanin après
l'attentât de conflans c'est une
réaction saine
saïd bouamama où c'est une chasse aux
sorcières pour vous le simple de
prononcer deux ccf suffit à montrer
qu'on est bien dans l' amalgame
qu'est ce que le ccf en organisation qui
est aujourd'hui reconnue par des
instances internationales comme l'onu
une organisation qui a
permis à certain nombre d' acte de
justice qui a passé par ces parties
civiles qu'elle a pu prendre permis à la
justice de le dénoncer sans d'actes
islamophobes et aujourd'hui le
s'essayait est présenté comme danger
pour la république il faut être vraiment
sérieux à ce niveau là on est dans une
logique dans lequel l'accusation
d'islamisme permis d'invalider tous ceux
qui sont dans la défense d'un certain
nombre de droits ou dans la critique du
gouvernement
on a eu la même chose vis-à-vis de ceux
qui ne sont pas musulmans avec le terme
islamo gauchiste on est aujourd'hui dans
le développement d'un vocabulaire et de
thématiques qui vise à silencieux les
critiques qui visent à empêcher la
réflexion et qui vise qui vise à nous
empêcher à tenter de comprendre les
causes des phénomènes pour pouvoir les
résoudre
on est uniquement dans le traitement des
conséquences et uniquement dans le xiii
dans le traitement autoritaire des
conséquences c'est extrêmement dangereux
parce que ça c'est compris dans chez les
populations des quartiers dans les
quartiers populaires c'est compris comme
une agression contre non pas les
islamistes mais une agression contre
tous ceux qui ont le malheur d'être
d'avoir une apparence musulmane ou
d'être musulman et les renards belle on
prend le problème dans le mauvais sens
et on exacerbe les tensions comme
l'expliquent votre contradicteur
vous savez la seule chose sur laquelle
sur laquelle je vais être d'accord c'est
qu'on a pas traiter le problème en amont
la mondiale était de traiter déjà le
problème de l'immigration massive
une immigration qu'on a laissé rentrer
en france depuis des décennies avec
aujourd'hui
depuis quelques années des gens qui sont
clandestins qui sont des demandeurs
d'asile des gens qui sont sur notre sol
qui n'ont rien à faire sur le territoire
français qui pour beaucoup sont
justement prêche prêche des choses
absolument effrayante et haineuse contre
la france dans ces mosquées donc je
pense déjà que tous et toutes ces luttes
contre les islamophobie devrait pas un
petit peu aussi
j'allais dire ceux se faire leur voix
devrait se faire un peu plus petit
quand on est à plus de 250 morts en
france liés tout tout au terrorisme
islamiste il faut quand même le dire
avoir le courage de le dire et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est il faut aussi
s'attaquer s'attaquer il faut prendre
les résolutions pour arrêter
aussi l'immigration massive reprendre un
contrôle sérieux aux frontières un
véritable contrôle aux frontières et
avoir de nouveau des frontières sur ce
territoire et pas uniquement pour le coc
vidé pour partir au ski
je crois que c'est sale ce serait ça les
décisions courageuses que devrait
prendre enfin monsieur darmanin mais si
ce n'est pas lui qui les qui les prend
eh bien nous on rassemblement national
avec marine le pen
cela fait des années que nous proposons
des décisions le contrôle ou la
fermeture des frontières et le contrôle
la fermeture intelligente des frontières
et le contrôle des frontières
l'expulsion immédiate des fichiers s et
des clandestins qui n'ont rien à faire
encore une fois sur notre territoire et
qui pour beaucoup encore une fois sont
compromis dans le désert pour certains
en tout cas sont compromis dans des
attentats islamistes
franchement il ya des mesures à prendre
qui sont plus importantes que de dire où
va contrôler 76 mosquées salafistes que
l'on connaît déjà depuis ce depuis très
longtemps
emmanuel macron a récemment donné un
ultimatum aux instances musulmanes pour
encadrer l'activité des imams sur le sol
français éviter notamment que les imams
vient de l'étranger
est-ce que
vous admettez qu'il faut une réforme de
l'islam de france est de bouamama crois
qu'il faut respecter la laïcité telle
qu'elle a été posée dans ce pays
dire que l'état ne rentre pas dans les
questions du culte et est indépendant de
tout culte et par conséquent la question
qui est posée c'est simplement d'exiger
à tous les cultes de respecter la loi
républicaine et il n'ya pas besoin que
l'état vienne s'immiscer plus
profondément là dedans mais je voudrais
réagir à ce que j'ai entendu juste
auparavant parce que ça montre bien à
quoi servent aujourd'hui ses effets d
annonces du gouvernement
en réalité on a un emmanuel macron qui
est déjà dans la préparation des
présidentielles et qui met en avant qui
agitent le cette question du terrorisme
en instrumentalisant l'émotion légitime
et mousson face au drame
après affreux qu'a été là ça se passe
d'être annulés pâtit qu'il est rien
instrumentaliser motion et pourquoi
faire pour imposer une vision bipartite
au moment des présidentielles
autrement dit un choix obligé entre la
surenchère que va faire le rassemblement
national comme on l'entend ce soir en
venant me parler d'immigration alors
qu'on parlait auparavant d'islamisme et
terroristes qu'on mélange tout pour est
dans tout et d'un autre côté macro on
veut nous imposer un choix pour les
présidentielles et pour cela on a besoin
de mettre au centre du débat
non pas le chômage n'ont pas la
précarité non pas la gestion du corona
virus on a besoin de nous mettre la
question d'un danger supposé que serait
celui des musulmans ou des supposés tels
rapidement level le mot de la fin très
rapidement ylénor à battre le mot de la
fin je crois que vous savez la france et
la france est depuis 2001 chrétienne la
laïcité on n'a pas attendu le suédois
mats pour en parler
la laïcité c'est déjà d'interdire le
voile aussi dans les espaces publics
c'est déjà verdict et instrumentaliser
une idéologie l'idéologie islamiste à
des fins politiques aussi et c'est
surtout je crois à un moment donné vient
d'agir réellement et de moi surtout de
des levées en fin de de baisser un peu
la voix quand on est quand on est avec
des gens qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
dans ces mosquées qui prêche une
véritable haine contre la france contre
la république contre la laïcité qui ne
sont absolument pas intégré n'est
assimilé à la république française
qui aujourd'hui viennent décapiter des
enseignants je pense que c'est ça qui
est là la chose la plus la plus
effrayante et je crois que pour le mot
de la fin est bien il va falloir que
gérald darmanin passe enfin des paroles
aux actes
et à ce moment là nous jugerons merci à
tous les deux ça idea bouamama eléonore
baisse d'avoir été avec nous et la
france seraient responsables des enfants
de djihadistes retenue dans les camps
syrien c'est ce que conclut le comité
des droits de l'enfant de l'onu dans un
avis que nos confrères de libération ont
pu se procurer ce comité avait été saisi
par plusieurs familles en 2019 pour le
moment exécutif campe sur sa position du
au cas par cas
estelle farges l'argumentaire français
ne tient pas c'est en résumé ce que
conclut le comité des droits de l'enfant
des nations unies sur le refus de paris
de rapatrier les enfants de djihadistes
retenu principalement dans les camps
d'al hall et de roches au nord-est de la
syrie
d'après le journal libération l'onu a
tranché la france est responsable
juridiquement de ses enfants
mieux encore elle a les moyens de les
protéger en organisant leur rapatriement
leurs conditions de détention représente
un risque imminent d'atteinte
irréparable à leur vie à leur intégrité
physique et mentale et à leur
développement
ils seraient environ 250 enfants
français dans les camps de syrie
malnutrition conditions sanitaires
déplorables mais aussi risque
d'endoctrinement l'avis du comité pointe
l'extrême vulnérabilité de ses enfants
la france de son côté a toujours affirmé
qu'elle n'avait aucune juridiction sur
les autorités kurdes qui gère les camps
d'al hall et de roches pour le moment le
pays mise sur la politique du cas par
cas une volonté réaffirmée par le chef
de l'état lors de sa visite au kenya en
mars dernier pour ce qui est des enfants
c'est une approche au cas par cas qui
est menée en particulier en lien avec la
croix rouge internationale
elle c'est une approche humanitaire qui
est suivie avec beaucoup de vigilance en
lien avec tous les acteurs qui sont sur
le terrain
si l'hexagone ne change pas de position
et ne se plie pas au droit international
il pourrait être condamné par le comité
des droits de l'enfant
mais cet avis pourrait aussi être
utilisée devant la cour européenne des
l'homme cette dernière a été saisie par
des grands-parents dont les deux petits
enfants sont en syrie si la france était
condamnée elle aurait pour obligation le
rapatriement de ses enfants est
peut-être le versement de dommages et
intérêts à la famille au québec à
présent les débats sont enflammés depuis
que le gouvernement de justin trudeau a
annoncé mi novembre que le français
était en déclin alors que c'est l'unique
langue officielle depuis 1977 de la
deuxième province la plus peuplée du
canada
le déclin de l'utilisation de la langue
de molière à montréal est en effet acté
par un démographe à l'office québécois
de la langue française
un débat qui touche québec en amont d'un
projet de réforme de la loi canadienne
sur les langues officielles qui devrait
être présenté courant 2021 et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec jérôme
blanchet gravel journaliste et essayiste
bonsoir jérôme blanchet gravel merci
d'être avec nous donc la langue de
molière qui serait en déclin au canada à
montréal notamment au québec
pourquoi pour quelle raison est ce qu'on
se l'expliquent
je voudrais que c'est un débat qui
revient très régulièrement dans la vie
politique du québec un set le français
s'est vraiment considéré comme le coeur
même de l'identité québécoise donc
évidemment c'est l'idée que la survie du
québec même passe par la survie du
français
donc évidemment vous connaissez les
géographies du québec l'a donc on est
environ 7 millions francophones sur 350
millions d'anglophones si vous comptez
les états unis canada donc quand on
parle du village gaulois c'est
nécessairement a justifié donc tous les
chiffres le montrent et c'est presque
presque consensuel la situation et
surtout problématique à montréal il
demain dans la métropole où l'anglais
avance de plus en plus de parts de pâma
géographie de par là l'ambiance
culturelle et tout
donc par exemple ce qui nous vaut
effectivement ont semblent ils serviront
une véritable volonté politique du moins
oui embryonnaire mais quand même assez
assez par qui qui s'exprime pour la
protection du français donc enfin
pandémie kobe 19 donc les forces
nationalistes sont optimistes elles sont
optimistes pourquoi parce qu'elles ont
des moyens de se défendre finalement oui
on peut dire ça parce que comme une
sorte de politiquement correct au tour
du français c'est à dire que tout le
monde tous les acteurs politiques au
canada je vous dirais s'entendent pour
dire que le français au québec c'est
important a donc ça fait partie c'est du
discours dont tout le monde dit oui
c'est un mental français mais ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour protéger le
français donc c'est ça la grande
question est là on sent que peut-être eu
la loi 100 qui la charte de la langue
française donc si la principale loi
c'est la loi qui protège le français au
québec on sent que on souhaite en fait
là renforcés par ceux qui ont dit qu'il
n'est plus n'est plus suffisante pour
protéger de france est donc un auteur
avec sa belle-fille eric lacroix qui
vient de publier un livre important
pourquoi la loi 101 cas d'échec donc
c'est un succès de librairie
donc les forces nationalistes ont réussi
si vous voulez à remettre à l'agenda
la question de la langue est peut-être
vont-ils réussir finalement à ce qu'on
passe des actions concrètes pour
protéger le français parce que comme je
vous dis c'est bien vous dire que le
français est important mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour le préserver c'est une
autre question la ccl on est dans le
concret et ça va passer justement par
par quoi cette cette fois ça va être
comme en france ya quelques années on
n'aura pas le droit de faire des
anglicismes là ça va être
à l'inversé comme ça que ça va se
présenter ouais c'est sûr que le dernier
la force des institutions mais c'est pas
tout il ya le rapport des québécois
eux-mêmes à la langue
le problème
un bloc plus sociologique c'est que le
français est plus précis et l'anglais
c'est à dire plus prestigieux que le
français est donc dans les universités
anglophones censure financé par rapport
aux universités francophones le système
de santé anglophone au québec est aussi
très frais financiers par rapport à
celui en proportion va passer une nuit
au système de santé francophone donc
c'est une question aussi de l'île
québécois au delà de la loi et au delà
effectivement d ajustement émotionnel
qu'on peut faire c'est aux québécois
aussi de se réapproprier une langue qui
est une langue internationale qui est
une grande langue qui le rend aussi de
la france qui est un pays banal dans le
monde
donc même si vous voulez mon avis est
que oui il ya les aspects juridiques de
tout ça est un aspect sociologique il
faut pas oublier que bien que c'est ça
que c'est aux québécois aussi heureux
même le valoriser la langue française au
quotidien et auprès de leurs enfants et
de terreur alors le projet de loi de
réforme de la loi canadienne sur les
langues officielles finalement que
peut-on en attendre
d'abord il faut que ça se concrétise
pour vrai c'est pas c'est pas gagné
d'avancé malgré tout comme je vous dis à
tout le monde sans tain je le répète
pour dire oui les français cet avantage
justin trudeau quand même admise mais
j'ai toujours dit que le français est
important mais il ya quand même montré
des signes d'ouverture à l'extension
d'un droit sans rien aux entreprises
sous juridiction fédérale ce qui est
important mais encore là ça reste parti
libéral du canada
il demeure des tensions entre les forces
nationalistes et les forces
souverainistes si bons qu'ils sont plus
marginalisés par les temps qui courent
mais qui sont quand même assez encore
présents donc tu quand même tout un jeu
de tension et d'opposition c'est pas
est-ce que ça va se concrétiser on ne
sait pas non plus encore exactement et
allait carrément également le goût jeu
que deux tendances tout avance plus
francophile une tendance plus anglophile
donc à l'intérieur même du bâtiment du
québec
il y a liant un clivage merci beaucoup
en tout cas jérôme blanchet grave est
journaliste et séisme nous avons rêvé y
voir plus clair sur cette situation et
c'est la fin de cette émission vous
retrouver pierre qui s'habille hivernaux
dans quelques instants pour un point
complet sur l'actualité de la journée
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le